as of yesterday we know president trump
is now considering
executive action on a coronavirus
stimulus package as white house
officials are now expected back on
capitol hill today
to continue negotiations with democrats
after talks
again stalled the president's citing
some progress with them but saying blue
state bailouts are off the table
we're having a very good discussion with
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
the problem is they want to do bailouts
of their
various democrat run states and cities
and they want a lot of money they want a
trillion dollars for that and so they
want to do much more than covet related
they want to do
they want to bail out cities and states
that have been in trouble for years of
bad management
in all cases democrat run cities and we
don't think that's fair
kristen fischer is live from the white
house with more on all this kristin the
president
is considering unilateral action if
capitol hill
can't get a deal done what exactly would
that look like
well the specific sandra are still being
hashed out but at that briefing
yesterday
president trump confirmed that he is
considering taking executive action
to stop two things payroll tax
collection and evictions
i can do that if i want and i want to do
that i don't want people to be evicted
it's china's fault it's not anybody's
fault it's china's fault
but number two and if they are thrown
out they oftentimes will go to a shelter
with tremendous numbers of other people
and the the virus will spread and we
don't want that
now president trump's push for a payroll
tax cut has not been particularly well
received on capitol hill by democrats
or republicans in fact they've shot it
down repeatedly but president trump
believes
that he may be able to act unilaterally
on this now
the white house's preference is still to
try to cut a deal on capitol hill with
republicans and democrats largely
because
there's only so much that the president
can do when he's trying to secure
billions and billions of dollars
of coronavirus relief funds but if they
do not cut a deal with sandra
the white house is preparing to act
alone on this all right so with that
being the big question what can we
expect today kristin in terms of
negotiations on capitol hill
well the top four negotiators are going
to be back at it on capitol hill schumer
pelosi minutia and meadows but
even after meeting for about two hours
yesterday when chuck schumer walked out
he still made it sound that they were
still in the very early stages of these
negotiations listen here
we are really getting an understanding
of each
side's position and we're making some
progress on certain issues moving closer
together
there are a lot of issues that are still
outstanding but i think there is a
desire
to get something done as soon as we can
and so we continue to work i would have
played for you what mark meadows or
treasury secretary steve mnuchin had to
say but they did not
speak in front of the cameras after the
negotiations yesterday but maybe they
will today
that meeting set for this afternoon
sandra it's a quickly changing and
developing situation i know you'll be on
it for us this morning kristen fisher at
the white house kristin thank you